[Music]
alabama let's start with a question from
jennifer i crave a sense of control from
growing up in a chaotic household but
now as an adult it's costing me my
relationships and inner peace
how do i keep my emotions and trauma
from holding me back uh jennifer i mean
josh your thoughts
[Laughter]
i was gonna say i think ryan wrote this
question under an alias that's funny i
thought you wrote this
question yeah jennifer i think it's so
um
well i think that's such a powerful
question because
it it really does speak to exactly what
we were talking about previously around
past ways of being in the world that
were actually functional
and i think that's really important so
you know jennifer i
i
a core part of my work is really about
self-compassion
and i think that this is really
important and for everyone who's
listening right now i invite you just
for a moment
to recognize that like there is
a five-year-old inside you
you know we all walk through the world
in our armor you know we've got our our
clothes and our shoes and our way of
being and our introduction and our
elevator pitch and we've got all of this
stuff
but beneath all of it there is there is
a five-year-old inside of us
and
that five-year-old
is very often just like
tugging us
on
[Music]
our shirt and saying you know see me
like see me love me
and so i think a really important part
of recognizing that the
past strategies no longer serve the
current
is bringing
first and foremost
self-compassion
to that five-year-old inside of you
who was trying to figure out life
and
for everyone who's listening it's like
what is the five-year-old inside of you
asking for right now you know does the
five-year-old need
more spontaneity or more creativity
connection
um
does the five-year-old need you to
just
like even physically put your arms
around yourself and just say i've got
you i'm here for you
you know it becomes very difficult to
move
forward
in your power
jennifer
unless you are taking your five-year-old
with you
and so i
you know
if that little five-year-old was
coming to you and telling you what it
needs right now
uh
just
holding
that five-year-old is really
very powerful
because we can't move to the well what
do you do and how do you unless unless
we are actually walking in integrity
with with that five-year-old
um and then the other person we want to
walk with integrity with is
the
person who's maybe
20 years older or 30 years older than
you so
i don't know how you how old you are
jennifer but if imagine you're 30 um
what is the 50 older what is the 70 year
old in you need
because there is a 70 year old in you
that is also saying
see me and love me and
um
be kind to me
and that 70 year old is also asking you
to kind of
let go of some things connect with some
things um
to see yourself that seven year old is
is also giving you advice and
psychologically this is called
continuity of the self um and
really what continuity of the self is
it's very powerful uh we
we think about uh astronauts will often
talk about this astronauts will often
talk about how when they go into outer
space there they
see
the
the blob of the earth as they get more
and more away from the earth they see
the blob of the earth and they recognize
that the blob of the earth is like a
pinprick
and
that that pinprick of the world
reminds them simultaneously of their
insignificance
okay your your insignificance
and your significance
your insignificance and your
significance and your
your
your power
as a person
and so what is continuity of the self
continuity of the self is often when we
are feeling triggered in a particular
environment or
in a relationship or when we shutting
ourselves down from love or
opportunities we are seeing ourselves
only at in this moment in time which is
the current me who feels threatened or
who feels stuck
um but just starting to call in
your board of advisors which is your
childhood self as well as your
your older self
and getting advice from them
allows us to develop this develop the
sense of continuity where we now are no
longer just in the moment with ourselves
but we are also in the moment with our
past and our future so i could speak
more about various uh
aspects of this and i'm sure we'll
jennifer as we get to other questions
they're going to be some
answers that connect very much with uh
what you are describing here
um as other strategies that are helpful
but i think just um
kind of breathing into
the beauty of you
not in a way that's
false not in a way that's forced not in
a way that says just be positive
but in a way that recognizes that
compassion
is extraordinary
um
[Music]
if you don't mind i'd love to again i'm
i feel like i'm being very nerdy here
but i want to kind of play out something
that happens in that we've all seen
as to why self-compassion is so
important
so
all of us have been into a restaurant
where we've seen
a little kid maybe 18 months old or two
years old
and uh there's this beautiful scene that
unfolds in front of us which is you've
got this little child the child sitting
at the table with parents or caregivers
and the child decides that now they're
going to go and explore the restaurant
they're going to go kind of look around
by the way they're gonna go say hello to
everyone they're gonna go and like
fiddle with the splendor and like do
what what your kids do
and the child does something so
beautiful the child climbs off its chair
and it like runs a couple of steps
forward
and then
what does it do it actually you you see
it and if you
if you do developmental studies and
psychology you literally see this
unfolding before your eyes which is the
child runs around runs i'm being curious
i'm being whatever and then the child
looks back at the table
sees that the parents or caregivers are
still there and then what does it do
does it go back to the parents or
caregivers no
it doesn't it explores even more
so what you're seeing here john balbie
the beautiful psychologist john bobby
described this idea as
what the child is doing is the child is
in a space of secure attachment
it is the knowledge that if something
happens
if i'm under threat
that my parents or caregivers are going
to be able to come in and help me
it is literally the knowledge of the
secure base that enables the child to
learn to be curious to take risks to
grow and to explore
so
this is what self-compassion does
self-compassion is that principle
psychologically applied to the self
you can't go through life without having
your heart broken
you can't go through life without
learning without losing your job
sometimes without things like just not
going according to plan
so
this knowledge that when
when not if when things don't go
according to plan
that you will love yourself and if
you're watching this video stream like
when doctors are going in to give bad
news we often ask them to do this to
like literally physically hug themselves
and hold themselves
because we often live in our heads
but we are tactile we are we are we are
human
so when we do this we grounding
ourselves in our
humanity and in our in our hearts and
there's something so beautiful in that
and so self-compassion is quite
literally the idea that when things go
poorly
you will hug yourself
you will say to yourself not you stupid
idiot why did you do that you'll say
susie you know you did the best you
could in the circumstance in other words
the knowledge
that you have your own back
is the essence
of what allows you to explore
to be curious
to be vulnerable
[Music]
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free